[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are exploring the question
what makes someone creepy oh and other
questions that we received from you
mythical beasts yeah there's lots of
lots of thought-provoking questions I'm
trying I'm conjuring thoughts wasn't
easy hmm
I'm having trouble conjuring thoughts
don't think they are warning conjuring
because it makes me think of the movie
conjuring and I just was talking about
it with someone last night and I don't
like to think about it
then why were you talking to somebody
about it because I'd love to talk about
it you do I just don't like to think
about it okay so we're gonna get we're
going to get into the the world of
creepy and some other things including
if we had like a triathlon of dad sports
what would they be and who would win I
got some alright I got some thoughts on
that other stuff too but first I wanted
to check in with you I've noticed
something that has happened a couple of
times have been visiting your home oh
yeah
you have nonchalantly said okay google
dim the lights in the living room or
something along those lines and they've
actually dimmed or they you know you've
you've you've you've spoken to your home
uh-huh and I know this is not that's
right we have a this is not a new thing
I have an intimate relationship with my
own and I am in the process of going
full-bore well yeah all morning I was
looking over at you at your desk I mean
just kind of seeing what you were
working on it seems like you had wasn't
all morning you were deep into figuring
out like how to how to talk to your
house yeah I think you even googled I
looked over at one point and you're like
how can I be as cool as link yeah it's
interesting when the good when you
google that directly have you done that
what pops up a wiki how which I wrote
no you want you want to talk to your
lights - yeah yeah I talked to my lights
well interesting thing is so I was uh I
was talking to Daniel who is the is the
reason that we we look so cool on the
Internet
he I mean no actually yeah it's Mike
Feldman he's the one that makes us look
so cool in the merch but Daniel does it
was not merch he he'll go out and get
some clothes for her sometimes to wear
on the show and he was in and I was
talking to him about you know I kind of
been looking like what smart well you
got to get the smart bulbs like you got
to get the bulbs that can that can be
spoken to or basically they register
with your yeah well you can do the bulbs
you can do the things that you plug in
but you can also have to do the switches
and the reason I wanted to do the bulbs
themselves and not just the I know what
you got is like a converter like you
plug into and then it can control on and
offer ya you plug it into the wall then
you plug the lamp into the thing which I
incidentally I got a couple of those
from a GMM episode I think it's where we
were we were remote controlling
Christmas lights or something and I was
like hey when we're done with that I
want to take that home and I hooked it
up and then I just ended up getting more
of them and I did get one that was
hardwired to my to my front porch lights
so that I could speak to my own
electrician do that or you get it I
didn't know I don't do electrical okay I
can't use a knife yeah I can't use fire
I can't use it
electrics yeah I because I'm gonna have
to get cuz I want it again I want to be
able to control like the front lights
like you know the lights right now
they're on like a timer but I'd like to
be able to control like the lights that
are on the house the lights up the
driveway and then all lights and but you
also got to get the anything that's like
an overhead light that's like we have
recessed lighting in most rooms and it's
like that's not a switch so now you got
to get the switch that you can be
controlled you want to talk to every
single light in your house all lights
that's too much well yeah you're the
judge of that once I can control
everything you're going overboard well
you know I'm going overboard because
Daniel no because no see you gave me an
idea of what it could be like to be cool
okay but you actually aren't okay you're
not as cool as I'm gonna be when I can
literally speak to every light source in
my entire house and let me tell you what
here's what here's what Daniel told me
about he said I've got a friend who did
this to their house and the reason you
need the smart bulbs and not just the
little converter is because these bulbs
can be programmed to change color and
flash and do all kinds of things based
on voice commands and this guy has
created a custom program for his
different friends and so he's like hey
Google Sandra's here and all of a sudden
it'll like flash red and in play like
don't don't don't like Google home will
like access a track connects to its
Spotify playlist so you think you're
cool now you wait you come to my house
and I say ok Google links here and just
see how cool you feel then well if you
get the right camera if your house will
know that I'm there I'm also doing that
and then you don't even have to say ok
Google links here which is an odd thing
to say call do you think you can program
an intelligent camera to recognize your
face and then play a specific track I'm
sure you can't no no yeah because
there's a missing connection no there's
not because you centers have you're
gonna basically rewire your entire house
so that when Sandra comes over it can
flash red yeah exactly it's not you man
it's not I mean that's novel what you'll
never do it interestingly I'm actually
surprised because well I for the reader
you know the reason I'm compelled to do
every single light is because it just
seems clean you know what I'm saying
like yeah but just having a couple of
lights you can control the looking oh I
got to get up and touch the light switch
for that one Sandra the lights that I
control are the ones that I never walk
past the switch or I don't want to walk
at all I want to roll around the ones
that I've got slug and be on a time to
speak to my house I mean I'm just saying
it's not gonna be worth it I mean you
did you want to be in bed
and say okay google turn off all the
light well I haven't gotten in there but
that's another great idea see that would
be but not with Sondra I have my
different lights that turn on all the
lights there's certain lights that I
want to turn on with the sunset that
happens automatically and then they turn
off at different times because you well
you can also set routines a Nuke light
turns off at like 9:00 the chair light I
got a I got a Nuke light a chair light a
couch light a front light in a back
light and that's all the lights I got
wrong all the other one that you switch
yeah so archaic you touch it for every
dose for it Rhett for every light you
have to name it you're gonna you're
gonna have to name 47 lights and then
you're gonna have to remember those
names and I'm gonna do cool names like
battleship light like b12 you're good
yeah you're gonna have to come up with
this I'm gonna be the only one who
understands it right and then you'll be
you got to talk to dad if you want to
light it you'll be you'll be included
with every one who never simulated okay
dad turn on light b12 it'll be like okay
Google turn on light b12
I mean well no they won't say b12
they'll say porch light and I'll say
c-17 I'm just telling you man you'll
have to see I'm exposing it I'm just I'm
looking out for you you don't like I
mean I'm basically a my limit of the
number of light like I can't remember
now it's like you just told me all of
them in the span of a minute okay good
but sometimes I'm like okay Google turn
on the couch flight and it's like I'm
sorry I haven't learned that yet it's
like it's very light what that's just
like takes the onus on the user error
you know another thing it's tough to
keep them straight man you're gonna have
problems here's the thing you can get
your lights to be tied into your
intelligent cameras and so that if you
happen to be out of town and someone
comes to your front door
if the intelligent doorbell or the
camera senses someone at the door it can
turn I could be a program between the
hours of blank and blank if you see
motion outside turn on this light and so
it makes it seem like somebody's turning
on their bedroom light or ironing on
another light I mean this is so smart
that's it they also they're on camera
and you
can see him and that keeps Sandra away
yeah it's Sandra's son reverse yeah
Sandra she's insulted when you call her
Sandra Sandra I'm gonna have a whole
thing for you when you come over man
and you'll be like oh I got to do this I
mean that's it's a it's a novel idea I
just it's the future man everyone's
gonna be talking to their house and you
and me like I remember in 2019 rest
started talking to his house in every
whichaway in too many ways you can talk
to in too many ways now I'm a fan of
like throwing something to the
television to start watching like watch
a YouTube clip or just start playing
music and playing music in certain zones
in my house like right I do that every
single day and I'm like I want this to
play everywhere we got a party but I
want this to play just downstairs
because Kristi's upstairs that's a great
system or Google's play only upstairs
disk in my bathroom and my bedroom
chrome chromecast Audio I bought a whole
stash of those before they before they
off the market but what and I don't know
why they did but what do you what do you
do now I mean that's a problem what do I
do
there's still some floating out there
you can rob I gotta be a new solution
you do Sonos not a sponsor no but I'm
gonna do the outdoor speakers - they got
to be hardwired - like a stereo head of
some kind
yeah go ahead every stereo headset go
ahead and buy a couple of chromecast
audios right now seriously they're still
floating around just buy a couple for
like 25 bucks okay just to have the
option because Google chromecast not
audio doesn't work with that system it's
a separate thing because it doesn't have
a 3.5 jack I don't know it doesn't but I
don't know if that's the reason why but
that's what Audio has right and this if
this were a tech podcast people would be
calling in and we don't tell my wife
this is my secret way of letting you
know I'd like to make your biscuits a
tech podcast and two guys who don't
really know anything about tech or gonna
say things like 3.5 jack like the
clicking clack of welcoming Sandra to
your house remember click and clack yeah
you call in and they would tell you
about
automobiles stuff one of them died
that's Ben and Jerry no you're talking
about click and clack they're NPR they
had to shut the the auto repair show and
then they were like wizards oh yeah I
didn't know one of them passed away yeah
I also didn't know that they invented
ice creams mm-hmm which I I'm glad they
did okay so we're not gonna just talk
about tech I mean that is the what the
podcast is about now but you know we
promised you we'd answer questions so
next week is all about tech and every
week after ok
well let's get into some questions but
first let's promote some merch well
we're in an ear biscuit t-shirt you know
looks good talked about meta I mean I've
got on an air biscuit t-shirt we're on
ear biscuits we're on this shirt now
there was a point in time when I would
have not wanted to do this but I've
embraced it so here we are marching it
up it's easier the show you know it's
easier for you listener to go out in
public with us on your shirt than it is
for us to do it that's true I would I
wouldn't wear this in public but you
should and it's a great shirt I wouldn't
wear it just because I don't like to be
on my own shirt I like to be in my shirt
true also we got mugs let's say the same
thing on them which is the name of this
podcast ear biscuits ear biscuits
all right mythical dot store just go
over them brows you'll be surprised
because there's something you didn't
know was there and now there's a lot of
tech a lot of tech at the store and tech
advice yeah you can buy the tech advice
there's a chat there's a chat button
it's like chat with someone live right
now and that's me so your Beck advice
and my answer to all your questions
mythical dot store 3.5 jack
I think it's millimeters three point
five millimeters Jack yeah that's
actually my tech name is Jack link you
want to answer some questions yeah let's
get into this man this is gonna be fun
you want to start with the creepy let's
start with the creepy
I mean I teased with it and then if we
don't what if we don't get to it that's
a good point this is a question from a
while back and then we never we never
got to it now we think it's the best
question well a lot of people its own
does that mean thumbs did up on Facebook
so they really wanted to hear the answer
to it okay
Angeline Betterman sometimes I meet
someone and without even speaking to
them or knowing anything about them I
get a vibe of this person is creepy
or this person is trustworthy and it
almost always pans out to be true does
this happen to other people and if so
what the heck are we picking up on well
I you know I think that it's from an
evolutionary standpoint it's definitely
advantageous to develop the gene level
skill of a sixth sense of knowing if
someone's going to kill you or main you
or otherwise violate you so it makes
sense in theory that we would have this
inexplicable sense of creepiness because
I am saying that creepy is correlated to
getting maimed or otherwise violated and
then personally I think I experience
this I think I do have a sense like if
you started showing me if you just went
through a lineup of people and I could
make split-second decisions of creepy or
like hot or both creepy or ha that's the
decision I'm it was creepy or
trustworthy Oh what do we go how do we
get to hi oh sorry is not sort of a
sixth sense thing usually it's sort of
like oh I look at them and find them
attractive in the same way that I feel
like I can look at someone and be like
Oh given my personal taste this person
is attractive or whatever but I think in
the same in the same instant instant I
could I could determine creepiness well
and I can do it to the same person
okay saying well let's and I
say that that person is hot let's
explore what we think I mean is hot
because they're creepy let's meet let's
explore what makes someone creepy or
what you think and I think don't you
feel the same
oh yeah but I I don't remember what this
was in a book or an article or something
but an instant message someone was
advising people on this exact thing
which is when you have this sense that
you can't explain that someone is creepy
you should always act on it and you
should trust your interview and you
should always act on it without apology
so trust you I mean you should trust
your analyst of of who you are be sure
instincts and don't feel like you need a
problem you should well you shouldn't
feel like you are you know don't judge
yourself in that moment where you're
like is there something in me that's bad
that I'm making a judgement about this
person that's just like well I don't
know but your safety is important and
I'm not saying you got to do something
just getting yourself out of that
situation
just trust your instincts and more often
than not they're right but what is it
that people are picking up on well the
first thing I think about are the eyes
and then the second thing I think about
is the mouth so I think about that area
like creepiness is not necessarily what
the eyes look like but the fact if you
got like and like if there's a stayer
happening and it's like well how would
you describe this like what about like
I'm looking at you now I'm just looking
at you right but and now watch the
difference what what what what's
happening because I'm trying to put a
name to that as what to me is creepy so
I'm just looking at you that's pretty
explicit though that's a facial as an
aggressive facial expression okay but
but I'm just talking listener somebody
isn't doing anything or the letters can
you just I think this this Mayan your
flared your nostrils and you raise your
eyebrows
no I didn't don't look at my nostrils
I'm covering my nostrils and I'll cover
my bras I'll cover my eyes yeah I'm just
looking at you
well you could be you could be surprised
you kind of just rate you just sort of
raised your eyes you opened your eyes
more i bugged my eyes a little bit I'm
not talking about like picking up on
facial expression you see I am if you do
my answer is if you bug someone makes a
bug bugs their eyes out it if you get
out if you bug if your eyes buggy eyes
compared not compared but paired with a
slightly open mouth
that's that's that's dead-on creepy okay
well I don't disagree with that but if
that just feels more obvious whereas I'm
talking about like you've got and I'm
starting obvious so think about this you
got Ted Bundy right I did you watch the
Ted Bundy tapes no and I don't know why
anyone did I watched a little bit of it
and I'm gonna watch hours and hours
dedicated to it my showers a demented
serie I watched a little bit of it well
a lot of people just loved it a lot of
people loved yeah hey I'm not afraid to
go against the grain I don't get it man
and the you know he the thing that made
him such an unusual serial killer is he
was like a handsome charming guy but I
bet I haven't seen it but I bet he was
doing that with his eyes it has nothing
to do with the expressions that he was
making of course it does so what do you
okay
keep going I mean you're essentially
what you're saying is that like if I
were to go into a room and somebody were
to go that way and I just made a very
angry I didn't do that gorilla face I
just worse yeah but you did a piece of
an expression but what if somebody is
actually coming in and they're doing
charming things I believe that you
probably could still pick up on
something creepy if if Ted Bundy has the
capacity to kill you but yet he also has
the capacity to be charming and to make
prolonged eye contact or whatever I
still think there's probably some
something and again I do think that is
something visual aural as in audio ish
that's what I was saying that you're
picking up on but I don't think I don't
think it's an expression I think it's
things more subtle like posture or
changes in tone of voice I'm saying in
whoa okay so what pot I don't know I
don't I'm saying that I'm saying I don't
know what it is I think it's super
subtle but I don't think it's like this
guy every time I look at him he he bugs
his eyes out at me all right but okay
it's just like a little bit of a stare
mouth breathing I think inexplicable
smiling where you see teeth well I'm
okay then I can't see my teaming up with
these criteria I'm just I'm just I'm
just picturing creepy people and I'm
describing them to you it's not rocket
science I mean everything I've said is
creepy right I mean if they're staring
and scratching like in it like you're
talking about creepy behavior though I'm
saying that like somebody walks in and
they've been instructed to follow a
protocol of behavior that is like you're
gonna walk into this room and you're
going to stand there and you're going to
remain stone-faced to people do this you
think one is trustworthy and one is
creepy and it isn't because someone made
a face is because someone has a face I
think if you nursing I'm saying and
there's something about their face the
structure okay I'll go the distance of
the eyes that's if the percent if the
percentage of body fat contained on the
face is below 7% you think some people
have 7% body of their body found on
their face maybe like a large headed
baby if you're if you're percent body
fat is 7 / 7 percent in the facial
facial or less if you're like gaunt and
they're just in the face yeah I think
it's like I mean
like I was walking down the street one
time and I saw she was named Walter
Scoggins in that his name the guy from
co-star with Danny McBride in Vice
Principals Goggins Walter Goggins isn't
a Goggin great actor hilarious guy he's
in the he's in that he plays the the
harpsichordist in that new HBO show that
you showed me I'm a huge fan of the guy
but he's got a creepy vibe I mean he's
got a creepy facial structure actually
that's what makes him so castable he's
got deep set eyes like me but I ain't
creepy because my cuz I got big fat
cheeks
oh yeah he's gotta weigh all seven right
I got I might have 7% of your body
I was I was late Lincoln and I were like
sitting in the hot tub and of course I
don't wear my glasses in the hot tub and
like I come up out of the water like my
hair slicked back and Lincoln sitting
next to me like we're both on a jet so
like a point-blank range and I come up
and he's staring at me like creepy and
I'm like what and he's like your face is
shaped like a like an upside down
diamond
he's like you got your cheeks he's like
you look so different without glasses
and I was like well my hair slicked back
I was like I look like granddaddy don't
I he was like your face is like a dot
well he didn't say I was like he just
had a diamond it's like straight across
at the top comes out a little bit comes
out a big piece here at them up at the
points of my cheeks and then how does a
diamond shape I mean like like your face
up so yeah I got a diamond face it's not
creepy no you're not creepy but more
like if you can see more the skeletal
structure of the face then you start to
get creepy and if you're scratching
something then you're off shut off the
charts yeah but you're looking for
something else I I don't know what it is
but I'm saying that there are these
intangible things that you are picking
up on and it's not your conscious mind
picking up on and that's why you
shouldn't again that's why you shouldn't
judge yourself because you're picking up
on something that you that
that you said is coming from like a
reptilian part of your brain that's not
some conscious process it's just this
but I instinctively a whole bunch of
other things like unkempt wiry eyebrows
like or if there's like four or five
that are just four or five eyebrows yeah
you got more than two eyebrows that's
doubling creepy
you mean eyebrow hairs okay like if
you're inexplicably smiling and but and
you don't see teeth but you but you're
doing something with your tongue like
you're licking your lips with your
tongue that's creepy
I think the problem actually is
trustworthiness like I'm all over creepy
but
thinking somebody's trustworthy that's
dangerous like you're giving somebody
the benefit of the doubt I I think you
got to be really careful with that like
yeah they might have a chubby face
chubby cheeks like me but they might
look trustworthy but don't trust that
and you'd it there is there like a Ted
Bundy there is a tendency to fall into
prejudice here right because people may
be like well I don't trust this person
actually because of the way that I judge
where they come from and that's
obviously bad I mean I'm not suggesting
you do that because that you know you
you get into some I'm kind of talking
about when you're in that when you're in
a vulnerable place and you you you get a
vibe even if you get a if you get a vibe
of trust worth it is yeah you defy the
trustworthiness go into business with
the person know and trust your instincts
start a business right on the spot know
partnership I'm disturbed that you were
not able to say one thing that you think
makes people you're like creepy blind
no no because my theory is that what
makes somebody creepy is not something
that I can articulate is something that
happens in the reptilian part of my
brain and the reptilian part of my brain
cannot speak cannot form words can't
even really form thoughts in the same
way it just acts on instinct
in effect and I'm saying that there and
I'm sure that what they've done is
they've done some study if we were not
lazy if I didn't want to roll around
like a slug and turn my lights on with
my voice yeah then I'd probably Google
what makes somebody creepy and there
would be an answer but you know what
that's what that's what the Internet's
for that's not what your biscuits is for
I think there was a Vsauce of it you
know what makes something creepy though
there you go Vsauce has already done it
why were you sitting here talking about
it he didn't say why people look creepy
because that you know that'd be a stupid
that'd be a stupid video to make because
you you draw a lot of well I'll think
you're describing me link us to the and
leave that to me on our podcast which
other I'm sorry if you have a like a
like a skeletal face or that you lick
your lips I mean I'm just saying to me
you're acting creepy and you need
because you need to stop it well link us
to an actual scientific article hashtag
your biscuits will read it others will
too
here's another question from Megan
Martin what is an experience you had as
a kid that you wish your kids could have
but can't and then the opposite what is
an experience your kids have know that
you wish you were able to have as kids
okay do you do you know what what you
wish our kids could experience that they
can't but we did well I think it would I
think about this quite often and we
we've touched on this in general before
but you know just just the the amount of
freedom whoa I almost threw that off the
table the amount of freedom that we had
growing up which I think was partially
regional and partially generational yeah
being able to go off and do whatever we
want to and that is not something that
our kids even have the capacity to do at
this point because they got I can track
their location on their phone summer
time bike excursions but this specific
thing that I was thinking about was
something we talked about recently that
we did not that me and you talked about
that we've never we've never talked
about publicly was we were trying to
remember when we were our sons ages so
like maybe even younger than lock select
right 14
13:15 it was like maybe the summer
between eighth and ninth grade mm-hmm
which incidentally is the setting for
our upcoming novel la causes the Willie
Creek pre-order it now Malik Creek
dot-com takes place in the summer of
1992 but anyway we had a friend Ben who
what we talked about him before Ben
Greenwood the book of mythicality was
dedicated to Ben he was an embodiment of
mythicality if there ever was one passed
away from cancer years ago he was this
incredibly adventurous guy who got us
into so many things and somehow he
stalks his parents and then we talked to
our parents into letting us travel they
drove us in the green woods Subaru from
Buies Creek to Buckhorn Dam which was
it's basically the beginning of the Cape
Fear River the Cape Fear River
headwaters were a little bit higher than
that but this is like there's a dam
there and you have to like go over the
dam and we right got into a canoe the
three of us Ben's canoe or Ben's dad I
don't know whose canoe it was Ben's
canoe an old town canoe Green that was
definitely not a whitewater canoe it was
like a pond canoe but we took this canoe
there's like two seats in a canoe and
then there's a crossbar and then we
would take turns who sat on the crossbar
and we no supervision no phone we just
canoed all the way down the Cape Fear
River all the way back to our homes and
is a day long freakin way I mean it it
probably I mean it was at least a
six-hour journey yes and like we on the
river there was no life multiple rapid
I'm gonna check in with you guys when
you get to you this like Locke and
Lincoln and a friend getting into a boat
driving what dry driving them like an
hour and a half away again just having
them by hopefully you make it well we
you know we worked we worked up to it I
mean I think the reason they had the
canoe was because he could take it to
like the
lake on the golf course we did it all
the time yeah and and then it's like
well on the far side of the golf course
is the Cape Fear River so we could we
could take it there we cross the river
in the canoe yeah yeah or just swim or
whatever there and then we would take it
from there down to r1 but then at some
point you're like let's start at the
furthermost point and it yes right below
that dam like the water is like water
falling down over that but yeah it's
just crazy to think I just can't imagine
doing that with entrusting Locke in
Lincoln with that well and I I just
always think what does it mean you know
I actually think that my kids are you
know the they're a lot like me they're
they're supernaturally independent and
like would do a lot of things without
any the you know push back but there are
times when I'm like no doubt our
tendency to do things like get into a
boat because I'm not saying it wasn't it
it still wasn't normal our other friends
weren't doing it I mean true there were
some people who were doing it and it was
sort of we left it and we wouldn't be
doing if it weren't for Ben initiating
right we needed somebody to let us know
that it was you could it what could be
done but I have to think that our
decision to do a lot of things like that
and having it be awesome and then having
it turn out well is one of the reasons
that we've kind of lived a life of what
some people interpret as risk risky
behaviors at least in terms of like
taking chances on things and trying new
things sometimes I worry okay our kids
don't have that they don't exercise that
level of Independence and so is that
gonna come back to haunt them are they
gonna are they just gonna happen in a
different way yeah like I think it's
sense of adventure for them so let's go
to a rock climbing wall or like when I
when I was on this one stretch of
mountain biking with Lincoln I did
realize that if if he if he fell off the
bike to the left he would fall down he
would Kareem down a cliff right I was
like oh this is this is cool I bet I bet
he's scared right
now I didn't ask him later because I
realized we were going down the wrong
path and we had to turn around and I was
just very apologetic that we had to like
push our bikes back up this really
steamed push huh oh but yeah I had to
look on my phone in order to figure it
all out which we had none of that of
course when you're on a river you kind
of it's easy to not get lost because
it's there's only one direction right
only one river but you know the thing
about Ben said he embodied mythicality
and the you know it's a it's a credit to
his parents that they were I can't
remember what we told our parents oh
we're going out with Ben on the river
you know it's like I don't know how much
they really understood but it was very
clear that Ben's parents knew what was
going on because they're driving us they
are dropping us off yes there's no
question my parents definitely did not
know the extent there wasn't that it
wasn't that level of communication was
like I want you to tell me where you're
going I want you to wanna know
specifically I want to see on a map I
want to know when you're gonna get there
they were just like oh the green ones
got it good right and the great but the
to their credit okay you know when I
think about it I just wonder if I don't
know maybe this is a silly question but
because Ben's life was so so short and
he you know he had he was diagnosed with
chronic fatigue syndrome I think in
seventh grade so like he no longer could
even come to public school with us but
like and then he was so limited that
like whenever he had the energy to do
things and we were doing things with him
it was like he had a little bit more
freedom to experience I mean he he
experienced so much of life especially
given the the physical limitations that
from which he suffered mm-hmm I think
it's I don't know I take some comfort in
that and I feel honored that we were
along for the ride literally a lot of
times in his boat but it you know maybe
there was some sort of sense of you know
life is short go for it you know I I
think that maybe his parents had a sense
of that
hmmm that kind of led to yeah we'll drop
you off here and like we trust you to be
safe he had a good head on his shoulders
and he was like he was smart about all
that type of stuff you know wean and we
trusted him with our lives you know oh
the only thing I'll say that makes me
think that I don't I mean maybe they
were that maybe they they acted that way
without even realizing it but you know
he was that way from as far back as I
could remember when I met him in third
grade and yeah he had also he told
stories of Oklahoma which is where he
moved from you know all the stuff that
he went third grade you're not that old
right you haven't lived a whole lot of
life but he had already done so many
cool things you know in in and so I
think they were just very they trusted
him and he was super responsible and we
just did a but you know is again it was
a different time not that we didn't
almost die on the river many times but
but you can ask once we got our Guyot
you need that well and that's the thing
like is so difficult to then try to map
that onto our kids lives because I don't
you know I think about I mean you got
Lily driving right now right she's
starting to learning to drive and you
know when we were 16 no no I guess we
were 17 at the time I mean you just got
into a car and drove to India Indiana
from North Carolina well we were going
to a wedding yeah but I mean I mean you
were meeting your parents there it's
just a road right but yeah that's kind
of it's a long ways but it's for 17 year
old especially back then when it was
like literally it was a map we had a map
like a paper map didn't we I thought we
followed we didn't follow your parents
no because that wouldn't be as fun I
think we talked them into not following
them yeah as they drove to so I would
you know we'll meet you there okay no
because when we got when we we got to
town and we met
my grand my granddad remember that yeah
driving along the road anyway but the
opposite of the question is I don't know
what the answer is I mean there's lots
of things that I'd like my kids to be
able to experience but I'm also glad
that they don't they're not doing
anything as risky as we did so it's
really tough to answer but what did they
get to do that we kind of wish that we
got to do well the first thing that
comes to my mind is like I mean our kids
our kids come to the studio and they're
in videos and stuff I mean I think we
will be eating it up if that's true you
know if if we had access you know I mean
we're still that's why we're so you know
we're living our childhood dreams that
we didn't couldn't even articulate so
it's like man if I mean your dad worked
at the looked at the law school and they
just happen to have this like the this
setup with two VCRs and and you thought
well that was our opportunity to edit
video for the first time but that was
like heaven
it's like I'm going and I got dad's key
and I'm going into the to the two VCR
room yeah I mean it's like think about
if it wasn't two VCRs but it was this
like hey I can be on my dad's show or
something you know it's like an art you
know we we filmed we're filming some
stuff we film selfish and oh all the
time
like getting them into it because
they're so stinking cute and the way
that they play off of each other is
hilarious because they're so different
well then we did a similar thing with
Locke and Lincoln back what are the
mythical show you have a mythical show
minute to this segment yeah I was like
they when they were cute but they don't
but they're not but they don't want to
be a part of it it's not like they're
living a dream it's just like they get a
kick out of it
I mean Lily actually said you know I'd
like to be in a video again she still
thinks yeah she was she did some stuff
last year yeah when we she's gonna come
in next week and like watch us film some
stuff she's excited about it so I'm glad
that they do
for that way but like we our minds would
have been blown man if it was like I
don't know maybe we wouldn't care I feel
like we would have grown up if our dads
were like worked at the public access
television studio or something I don't
know what the economy what the
equivalent
well I the first thing that came to my
mind was the stuff that our kids get to
do and this is a you know partly because
of our jobs and probably because of
where we live but also this is a much
more travel oriented generation there's
yeah just it's much more you know people
fly a lot more people go a lot further
but just like I think about the
vacations that we've been on with our
family their kids have been to Australia
our kids have been to Europe and you
know locks been to Africa you're you're
gonna be Lilly went to China to China
then you're gonna friend to her and
you're gonna be in that part of the
country a part of the world again you
know and our kids get to eat all this
amazing food when amazing food for me
was Bush oh nice yeah amazing food in LA
yeah went around the world to in and I
don't know because I feel ya would have
been nice to be spoiled like our Co
obviously which is I'm of two minds
about this though because I kind of
think that the fact that really up until
I graduated college Shoney's was still
that was as good as it got for me you
know what I'm saying like I think that I
mean I'm able to even I think you were
just pretty quickly but I think I'm you
know I'm able to kind of appreciate that
we didn't we didn't go any we didn't we
traveled a little bit we would like go
to Georgia you know remember that family
but at that time that my mom took me and
you took Carowinds
yeah I never forget it because those
kinds of things were so there were
anomalies in our experience it was just
going to an amusement part in there
Charlotte pretty awesome yeah but a
blown I'm gonna go to Carolyn's is that
what you're asking on our minds to go to
Six Flags I would have been that much
different yeah so I don't know I in one
sense I think what I'm saying is there's
things that come to mind that I would
like to do and I'd like them to do but
in another at the same time I'm kind of
glad that I had the life I had and they
have the life they have you don't have
the power to change let's just reconcile
yeah just accept it Jonathan Garlin
house if you guys would have faced each
other in a quote dad sports triathlon
and then in parentheses you put darts
pool bowling is this a thing or did he
make that up is it dad sports triathlon
a thing and it consists of darts pool
and bowling his question is what
strengths would you bring to it and who
would win overall well I mean I'm I am
NOT I'm trying as hard as I can when I
throw darts on the show yeah I mean I'm
just oh yeah it's got no chance man and
we're sit we're so close to that board
and I'm horrible at it but I don't think
your weakness is the targeting it kind
of I think your weakness is the guessing
no are you it Oracle II that far from
your guesses yeah I mean if you order
like if you were to superimpose like an
actual dartboard and the the amount of
fidelity there I'm telling you I think
somebody should do that that would be
horrible at it but we've we have well
pool not great at that you're not good
at so you would beat me at darts well
but we've done pool and bowling on well
okay if we if we're judging this by
performance on good mythical morning
I actually think historically you would
win we play pool one time and you were
you thought you were better at it than
me I don't think I'm that bad of a pool
player but you beat me on that day and
and then bowling when we did the flame
bowling I was back at least dinner at
least in the Edit you you got more of
the strikes no I'm I'm if we're bowling
one game of bowling one one is it called
around I don't know what is a set
what it's called frame I would I think
I'd beat you but if we went to my
fingers give out but here's the thing
though is that if you isolate this down
to pure pure competition and not an
entertainment value not be like it's not
being filmed mm-hmm and it's just simply
like it I kind of go into a very
specific mode in those scenarios
yeah which sends me into another mode so
your mode is I get very competitive I
have to win I would be tough to beat
it's not just about winning yeah and it
sends me into my mode which is I'm
searching for it I'm searching for a
motivation yeah I'm just like I really
don't like even in winning I'm like
looking around like for some sort of
like an instruction manual
like I don't like yeah I just I don't I
just don't really well it's it's the
winning is the reward I don't really
care that much the witnessed the it's
the winning that's it I do think that
not at the champagne I might not really
I might could really work up some
gumption and I think I could beat you at
bowling I think I think that would be a
good competition I also think definitely
be close I think like frisbee golf I
think that would be pretty even like I
like to think I'm pretty good with a
frisbee yeah
yeah we we've we did that we used to do
that in college but I blow you away at
napping is that a dad that's a dad thing
I'm just saying yeah dad's gonna like
sit like hit the couch in this who's
gonna go out first like I could
definitely blow you out of the water I
can't I can't nap competitively like
that's that's a given I mean after we
had that meeting but before we came in
here you snored within 30 seconds well
yeah I laid down on the couch I was like
I'm gonna take it we got a meeting in 12
minutes I'm gonna take a 12-minute nap
and Jayde was sitting on my lap and I
even had to pee and I had to move Jayde
because she was on my bladder hmm I
to pee I had a dog sleeping on top of me
because she's constantly sleeping and I
know I fell asleep because I did that
jerk thing you're such a jerk
I did the jerk I actually looked it up
did you see it's called a hypnagogic
jerk yeah did you you said I was snoring
is that with in it with no exaggeration
within a minute there was a cop there's
like a that was that was when I jerked
oh yeah also called a hypnic jerk or
sleep starts sleep starts sleep starts
like I get I think that's short for like
startled okay yeah I know how did that
what I had that happen but in a 12
minute in a 12 minute that's why I'm a
little grumpy right now 12 minutes 12
minutes help well it should have been I
think it should have been 20 minutes his
power nap right not 12 minutes but a
12-minute nap would not I even under the
best circumstances I wouldn't go to
sleep in 12 minutes
it would just be I'm resting my eyes I'm
really trying to go to sleep but I
literally went to sleep in a minute
again so it's like I'm saying let's put
that in there but that's not part of the
triathlon it's just darts pool and
bowling and you know we wrapped about in
that thoughtful guy thing we talked
about the hypnagogic jerk and it's like
a wonderful sad defense mechanism for
something like sleeping on a cliff or
just top bunking you know they don't
know why it happens but it's the same
reason you find people creepy the the
prevailing theory if you're interested
is that like from a from like a
evolutionary like primal version of us
it's like sleeping if you feel like a
like a primate sleeping in a tree like
if you if you if you fall asleep then
you're like the the relaxation of your
muscles then triggers a reflex to like
grab to grab so you don't fall out of
the tree I thought I don't fall out of
the womb as a baby that's not up to you
that's up to the womb oh so I think we
were right about the top bunk
or like sleeping on a cliff sleeping in
a tree it's when that jerk happens that
makes sense to me
so I'm winning it that to some well you
at or I could add golf to the dad thing
and then I win I mean if we're adding
things that were good at then we can
just add ad nauseam getting nauseated
I'd win at that how about another
question when one last question before
we the reckon effect okay this is from
Austin camping touches on something
we've talked about before but this is a
different analysis because they touch it
if it was confirmed that we were in the
matrix or some equivalent simulation
which of course we are and they're your
words that was this is Austin he's
saying all this oh and there was a way
out would you take it you'd be leaving
your family friends in life behind for
an unknown real world would it be worth
it so obviously we talked in fact we we
made a valiant attempt to escape the
simulation right we tell on this very
show we two guys are linked and read and
we know we are in a simulation and we
want out it did not work unless we
escaped into a simulation that was
exactly the same as the one we left
because you were in us there's no way to
prove that we didn't and so you kind of
answer the question that like if we
wanted to escape you were you were
having some some alone time and you were
thinking about if you were if you could
break out would you and you said out
loud I was in the hot tub and I said I
know this is a simulation let me out now
or something I want out and I won't out
because I thought that maybe that was
the key was just to acknowledge it but
then we tried it his buddy's holding
hand doesn't work his place but but but
I think I didn't catch your answer but
your answer at the time was to it and
you seemed to just drag me along for the
no and okay here's what here's what I'll
say my knee-jerk your hypnagogic jerk my
hypnagogic jerk answer to this question
is that by default I would get out of
the simulation because it would be
moving towards truth right so it so you
know I'm gonna
about it on a second on the second level
and maybe take it back but I'm saying my
knee-jerk reaction to it is oh this is a
simulation but yeah there's a truth
beyond that that you can actually ascend
to yes I'm gonna go there regardless of
what's on the other side and you say a
sin but it may be descended - yeah it
could be think that's the point yeah
but Austin has got me thinking
differently about it because now all of
a sudden what he's saying is that okay
Austin had to remind you that you have a
family well no sigh okay so you you in
you know obviously our family but you've
got your you dog Jayde is in the room
where this ends lap over there so and I
don't have any proof of this but you
seem to be as attached to Jayde as you
are to any human that you are in
relationship with now for a moment
consider that Jade is not real she is
only she's just the result of some
clever programming but by definition
excising yourself from the simulation
would mean that you could no longer be
in relationship with her not doing it I
mean I'm you know
yeah I got too much I got too much to
lose man look at me I got it going on I
mean you're painted a simple you've
painted a simple picture for me but it's
not real it's not real neither am i no
no that's exactly no you are real and
you can get out now maybe Jade is an
avatar of another dog that you can make
a connection within outside of the
simulation maybe your wife is an avatar
of another individual that you can make
a connection with outside of the
simulation I don't know if the
simulation exists just for you or if
we're all avatars in a simulation we do
you don't know that until you get out of
the simulation why would the you know
why would it it seems it seems easier
for me to believe that it would be worse
look outside of the simulation because
I'm biased because I've got I got a
hashtag blessed life okay and it's so it
seems like but it seems cruel that it's
all fake it's all a simulation so it
seems like that cruelty that set it up
seems cruel wasn't seem cruel because
it's not real your hashtag blessed men I
know but I'm just saying on a but it's
but it's a farce
it's a lie it's alive it's a favor I
guess to me maybe it is maybe it's just
an experiment I don't know but you know
if I knew definitively like this is the
thing is that how could it be better I
mean again it's like I'm the people in
the matrix had the head that they were
they came out of the matrix and saw the
real world and then made decisions to
stay because I could come back right but
I'm just saying this is like an
all-or-nothing deal like if you if you
leave you can't get back and you don't
know what's on the other side for me the
unknown and the fact that it is a
simulation and you can get
out of it the mic the curiosity is too
high and then I would just justify it I
would be like of course I love my my
family first I love my life but if they
are ultimately just a program then I'm
not really I'm not really and I'm just
I'm just in inside the simulation I'm
not really I'm not losing I'm losing an
idea I'm not losing actual beings again
this is like the robot relationship
conversation I thought we became
convinced that like yes we could have
what would experientially be a viable
relationship with a robot and we were
cool with that but that's self-aware
self-deception
so just extend that to an entire family
of robots that you're it's like surprise
your family is robots I just think the
fact that you don't that there's
something that you could know that
there's something on the outside that
just it's too much with the with the
robots I know what the alternative is
and I can slip into it anytime I can see
Stu I can be like this relationship is
just with a robot or I can enter into it
make myself believe it
but that makes it sound like given the
way you describe it like okay you would
go to Mars you would leave you would
leave your family to discover the next
frontier no because my family is real in
that scenario
I'm leaving people who have the capacity
that not only is it what I feel but they
also have the capacity to grieve but
this in the simulation they do they
they're basic they do they could they
would grieve yeah but I if my if a robot
was about to kill my dog I'd kill the
robot do you know what I'm saying I
don't know how that applies it's like
you don't you know someone's not about
to your family members not about to kill
I have a bias towards biological life
sue me I have a bias towards my own
current happy okay I mean that's cool
man I I don't know what happens to me
when I leave the simulation one day I'll
figure it out I don't know if my body
just dropped your life and I just died
the chances of again I've there's
there's a lot of people who are living
difficult lives I mean we are in a
percentage of people on earth who are
living like I mean we don't deserve how
good we've got you're assuming that that
chance is that it's better than what
we've got but you're assuming element my
primary motivation is increased comfort
I mean I do want to speak to my home as
a slug I know that isn't that is true
right but my primary motivation for
moving into the next thing is not
increased comfort as much as its
increased discovery I think your primary
motive is seeming like you could take a
provocative stand no I know
see cuz if you were to adopt my opinion
that would be true about you but that's
not sure about me I want Sondra to come
over because I want to discover what it
would be like for Sondra to have a
special slant rights give me an example
of when you have sacrificed present
comfort for a future discovery for
potential discovery potential discovery
it happens all the time like tasting new
Carl's jr. burger so what you're you're
denying yourself what what are you
denying what do you don't know how it's
gonna go down man the lame example okay
rack your brain hot chicken is that
comfortable
I wanted the hottest one to see what it
was like I didn't think it was gonna be
but it would but if Instagram didn't
exist would you you would have done it I
did it the other day with no Instagram
that's true
no but also I don't it's not much of a
song but no I think our whole career
though I don't think that it's been
primarily motivated by more
Comfort no that's true any but any type
of life like you in the Spartan Race
it wasn't about comfort there's about
self-discovery man I think it's human
nature if you're like listen I can't
promise you what this is going it's
gonna be like when you go into this room
it could be really bad it could really
be good the thing is is if you go into
this room the thing I can promise is it
will be mind-blowing you're not gonna go
in that room I'm gonna go into that room
but you neck can never come back from
the room yeah that's the thing okay I'm
going in man that's the problem I'm
going in you can't the problem is coming
back like we don't think we've been
faced with that well I don't think I'm
trying to come out the examples that you
give it or not like that like it's a
valve
you can't go back tattoo getting a
tattoo no you got to keep thinking man
I'm not convinced that you would do it
I'm just saying as long as a priors no I
when I was in the hot tub I was really
trying to get out and I was really
trying to get out when we were here okay
I wasn't that's why I had so much fun
trying let us know what you would do
hashtag your biscuits but I do want to
leave you with a wreck and effect oh
yeah give me a wreck man it's your turn
uh check my big chick I'm I tend to
recommend shows I've noticed I recommend
another another show for those of you
like weird it's just it's weird and it's
not for everybody and that's why I like
it it just the second season just came
back on Netflix the Oh a did you reverse
that no I didn't anybody else in here
watch that it's a sci-fi situation yeah
and I'm not gonna basically what the
show is about by telling you what the
show is about is is basically a sort of
like the season one spoiler so I'm not
gonna do that it just because you once
you figure out what what's going on it
so it's it's a little bit of uh there's
a little bit of a mist
aspect it's just super weird so if you
like weird sci-fi yeah is it like black
mirror there it has black mirror ish
elements in that you know they're kind
of delving in and asking some some
philosophical questions of what if this
could happen what if this were true and
it is a concept that you know people
have explored them in philosophy and
it's kind of just exploring what it
would be like and then are there any
jolly laughs it is not funny at all it
would be nice if it was funny it's not
funny at all
it is the writing good is the acting
good is it more about yes the writing
and acting is good is there any stars
that I would recognize you would
recognize the antagonist but I don't
know what he's from but you would
recognize him okay and then the second
season and we just started watching that
Jesse nice one of the shows that we
enjoy together just started watching
that and it was just like Oh cuz I was
thinking where they couldn't go are they
gonna go from here they're rated R is it
for the negative for the kids
mm-hm it's not bad I don't think you
kids could watch it can I start with
season two no definitely not okay I
honestly away I don't know if you'd like
it because I it's just one of those
things that it's like it's weird in fact
and then you know my good friends Lance
and lacy who are you know kind of the
authority on weird without being
prompted they just texted in the text
thread that where they have with me and
Jesse never like you gotta watch the Oh
a super weird I think you'd like it and
we were like oh we love it we watch it
together you don't think I would like it
well I got a limited screen the thing
I've observed trying to kill thing I
haven't have observed about the way that
you analyze television shows and movies
is you have a difficult time enjoying
things that don't have likable
characters and this is not I don't find
the main character particularly like
and I don't find anybody very likable
but I liked I liked the shade or I liked
Handmaid's Tale but I didn't like house
of cards at the beginning but I watch
you also didn't like that what's that in
that show on Showtime
or maybe it's HBO that's about the rich
family that's supposed to be like the
other descendants the supposed to be
like Rupert Murdoch's family so
succession you you didn't like that when
you started watching it because you're
like I don't like you any of the people
and I'm like yep that's why I like it
because I don't like any other people
yeah so if you don't it's so harsh if
you don't if you like to watch shows
where everyone is unlikable
you'll love the Oh a really ok it's but
it's not like that it's not like the
main character is just the protagonist
is not a jerk and you don't like hate
them they're not like morally corrupt
it's loved house back I don't think you
he's very like he was so unlikable he
was likable and that was the device
there you go okay maybe they're sounds
different all right I'm gonna tell my
I'm gonna tell my house to play the next
episode of a way for me see yeah see how
it responds house whenever I walk up to
you and enter your front start playing
the Oh a on every screen what if I asked
the house to play house it might just
implode well it's probably smarter than
that like play myself what right down
you want your whole house to collapse
ask it to play house yeah hashtag ear
biscuits talk to us keep listening
don't give up on us yeah it'll get
better
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
you
[Music]